[Music]
I'm Keith Olbermann and this is the
resistance more than 36 hours after
Donald Trump revealed the full extent of
his disconnect from reality the
jaw-dropping terrifying moment in which
the president-elect of the United States
of America publicly stated he believes
the election was still rigged against
him even though he won it and we still
await the first serious sober discussion
in our nation's media about the exact
dimensions of and the exact nature of
mr. Trump's desperate psychological
impairment this has long since
transcended politics this has long since
transcended diversions from his
corruption or from the FBI or from
foreign interference this is not left
versus right nor liberal versus
conservative nor alt versus inclusive
nor any of the excuses that newspapers
and television made Sunday and Monday in
hopes of preserving the political media
complex this is not funny
and this is not ego and this is not oh
he just speaks his mind this is an
existential threat to the United States
of America the president elect Donald
Trump is manifestly profoundly and
dangerously psychologically imbalanced
the sooner we acknowledge this the
greater the chances we have of averting
a disaster which could threaten the
safety of every American indeed of
everybody on this planet the sooner
those around him acknowledge this the
greater the chances they have of not
being remembered by history if there is
a history to remember them as enablers
to a cataclysm in which the most
powerful military Arsenal in the history
of the world was placed under the
control of a man with no control over
himself at his hair-trigger
childish petulant peevish vengeful
hateful poisonous temper the sooner
those who plan to be in his government
acknowledge this the greater the chances
they have of summoning the support from
all political quarters before it is too
late to do anything constitutional about
it a Mike Pence presidential
administration is far from the list of
my 100 preferred options but right now I
cling to it
as the only realistic prospect of saving
ourselves from an insane
commander-in-chief a sane man does not
on a Wednesday promulgate a video in
which he claims it is prayer that we
begin to heal our divisions and move
forward as one country and then on a
Saturday insult the losing party as
badly defeated and demoralized a sane
man does not acknowledge the end of a
long and bruising political campaign and
that emotions are raw and tensions just
don't heal overnight and then three days
later brand a fully legal recount the
right to which he repeatedly reserved
for himself not a month earlier as a
quote scam and then a day after that
insists there was serious voter fraud in
three states that the media isn't
reporting a sane man does not invoke
Lincoln and a great national campaign to
rebuild our country at one hour and then
96 hours later insist I won the popular
vote if you deduct the millions of
people who voted illegally these are not
words of Saturday these are the rages
and the boasts and the madness that we
have seen throughout history sada
Hussein Mussolini Fidel Castro Mao
Zedong's Stalin Pol Pot bin Laden Hitler
if there are still doubts about what we
face and how our hands are tied just a
little more tightly every day if there
needs to be debate about how sick this
man is whether this is treatable
neurosis or an illness brought on by a
physical calamity or injury or full-on
malignant narcissism or paranoia or
psycho or sociopathy so be it we may
still have time for a national dialogue
about exactly what is wrong with him but
in pronouncing after arguably the
greatest upset in American electoral
history that he won of won by more
because the vote was still rigged
against him Donald John Trump has made
it in arguably certain that there is
something desperately wrong with him and
he is not psychologically fit to assume
the presidency next January 20th resist
peace